m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carquin
[Musique]
bell
dakar
[Musique]
ma
les gens
[Musique]
à
là
joe cocker il est 18 heures et 16
minutes où vous restez avec nous on
parle politique elle lundi politique
gagne le dantec de la lutte contre le
diabète ont retardé colis postaux en
passant par la réforme constitutionnelle
ou la défense de l'octroi de mer notre
invité tire dans tous les sens depuis
son nouveau siège à l'assemblée
nationale alors que sa réputation
d'universitaires plus intellectuel que
politicien laisser croire qu'il aurait
pu s'accommoder de la politique centre
droit de devoir payer pour le découvre
dans une posture souvent contestataires
se reconnaît-il dans le discours de ceux
qui affirment qu'il existe une place à
la droite de macron à des styles pour
autant la ligne wauquiez sur les
questions de société
nous lui poserons la question dans cette
émission nous lui demanderons également
ce qu'il espère hors commandes pour le
bien-être de la réunion quels projets
quelle direction vont t'ils défendre
avec l allier depuis un an bientôt il
fait des allers retours entre paris et
saint pierre quel bilan quel
satisfaction ou déception david lorion
députés les républicains conseiller
municipal de saint pierre est l'invité
de lundi politique sur la première
émission que vous pouvez suivre en vidéo
sur notre site internet
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'est comme tous les
parlementaires que vous avez des agendas
s'est chargé et pas mal de temps dans
l'avion dans l'actualité il ya d'abord
ce conflit autour du chantier la
nouvelle route du littoral vous avez été
vice président du conseil rural vous
connaissez le dossier comment est-ce
qu'on en arrive à cette situation où des
transporteurs viennent mettre la
pression parce qu'ils ont peur de
manquer de travail qu'est ce que vous
leur avez promis qu est ce qui leur a
été promis qu'ils pourraient
éventuellement ne pas être tenu il faut
bien voir que ce chantier est
exceptionnel dans sa durée dans sa
dimension dans sa complexité et
qu'aujourd'hui on est au coeur même de
ce chantier les transporteurs ont raison
évidemment d'avoir peur un moment donné
puisqu'il s'agit de leur métier ils
avaient beaucoup d'espérance sur ce
chantier ils ont toujours beaucoup il
reste évidemment de vastes chantiers
cette digue encore à faire c'est à peu
près la moitié évidemment du chantier
qui reste à faire et je crois qu'il est
nécessaire un bon temps et qui demandent
des précisions sur qu'est-ce qui va être
mise en oeuvre pour leur assure
évidemment du travail
il s'agit évidemment des matériaux qui
vont constituer cette digue de l'autre
côté on a aussi de grands professionnels
moi j'aurais salue évidemment dominique
fournel s'est chargé de ce dossier c'est
un beau chantier c'est un grand
professionnel dominique fournel je suis
sûr évidemment que les deux vont pouvoir
se rencontrer dominique fournel de la
région les transporteurs pour se mettre
d'accord sur une visibilité de des
entreprises de transport dans ce
chantier
je souhaite en tout cas qu'elles
réussissent parce que la réunion entière
pas seulement le chantier est pas
seulement la région mais la réunion
toute entière a intérêt évidemment que
ce chantier soit une réussite exemplaire
est ce qu'il ya eu des menaces qui est
une erreur de planning au départ est ce
que le chantier a été lancé alors qu'on
n'avait pas l'assurance d'avoir les
matériaux nécessaires à ce que vous
reconnaissez au début de ce chantier de
cette affaire peut être une erreur de
communication de planning ne je suis pas
le mieux placé pour répondre à cette
question je pense que ça la réponse peut
appartenir à la région mais vous savez
ce chantier a été lancé aussi parce
qu'il était une nécessité de sécurité et
donc il y avait aussi des financements
qu'il fallait capté à un moment donné il
a été lancé aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
le plus important il doit être terminé
il va être terminé
des bonnes conditions pour les
entreprises qui sont sur le chantier
mais aussi dans les conditions
financières de la région
on attend l'ouverture de carrière pour
pour ce pour ce chantier
il y à des associations notamment qui
pointe une anomalie vous allez me dire
ce que ce que vous en pensez en tout cas
peut-être un problème lié au fait que
c'est la même entreprise bouygues
en gros si on remonte un peu les
filiales qui qui qui vend les roches
puisqu'il possède finalement la carrière
mais qui aussi les achète puisque il
participe au groupement du chantier est
ce que ça pose un souci s'il y a des
plainte c'est la justice qui va se
prononcer là-dessus mois vous pouvez
difficilement imaginer que je puisse me
prononcer j'ai constaté j'ai lu comme
tout le monde depuis un certain temps
que les associations pouvaient dénoncé
le fait qu'on soit en même temps celui
qui commet mener celui qui finalement
qui livre là dessus on n'a pas beaucoup
de très grandes entreprises à la réunion
ce quart est arrivé assez souvent là
après s'il ya des plaintes et s'il ya
des erreurs qui ont été faites la
justice évidemment va a jugé on va
quitter un petit peu lors du temps mais
mais mais pas tant que ça david rien
vous êtes géographe de formation est
toujours aujourd'hui maître de
conférences saveurs géographie à
l'université
comment est ce que vous estimez vous
l'impact de l'enlèvement des andains
c'est pierre qui sont dans les dents les
shows pour les utiliser sur cette route
du littoral ou ailleurs mais le fait de
les enlever est ce que ça peut poser un
problème notamment au niveau du
ruissellement de l'infiltration des eaux
est ce que ça a été correctement mesurez
vous avez raison les andains on était
comme un peu les airs en bretagne de
leur mise en place justement pour
limiter les effets du ruissellement et
l'érosion superficielle demandé terre
nous sommes sur les terrains en pente
nous sommes sur les terrains où les sols
sont maigres et donc lorsque la réunion
les agriculteurs cultivent l'ensemble de
ses pentes
les anciens en quelque sorte ont
toujours fait attention qui est de moins
de ruissellement possible est la
conséquence est que plus abri seulement
et plus cette terre se retrouvent dans
les lagons notamment sur les côtes ouest
alors les autorisations d'un rêve
mandanda n'ont pas été donnés non plus
au hasard il y a eu un seul nom de
commission de la dea la direction de la
direction de l'environnement et
l'aménagement donc et du logement qui a
vérifié que les autorisations pouvait
donner de bonnes conditions
j'ose espérer que ce travail était bien
fait mais je peux que constater qu'il ya
quelquefois évidemment certain nombre
d'allusions cm de terre qui se sont
accumulées sur le littoral c'était et
c'est toujours géographe que que je vous
adresse monsieur responsables politiques
qui participent à l'aménagement du
territoire
la réunion a été durement touchée on l'a
vu encore durant les dernières les
dernières tempêtes depuis depuis le mois
de janvier
l'eau a dévasté des routes des maisons
de personnes ont même perdu la vie le
lagon à saint-leu notamment est toujours
pollués
alors il ya là les demandes d'enlèvement
des andains mais il ya aussi
l'aménagement global du territoire
est ce que il faut repenser tout ça est
ce qu'il faut est ce qu on a fait des
erreurs
ou est ce que finalement ça arrive
peut-être tous les 50 ans tous les sens
tant qu'il pleuve à ce point là et que
bon bah voilà ça finit par par uys les
parcs ou les est arrivé dans le lagon en
tout cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que les erreurs dans le domaine de
l'aménagement sont toujours très
préjudiciable sur l'ensemble de la
population
il s'agit pas tout à fait d'aménagement
du territoire mais sinon d'équipement du
territoire dans le cas présent lorsqu'on
a une île en pente comme la nôtre et
qu'il y a des totaux pluviométrique qui
sont aussi importants puisque la réunion
et recommande du monde un certain nombre
de tokyo métriques les deux ensemble
font qu'on a des ruissellements
superficielle très important
d'autre part la l'urbanisation la
dynamique de l'agrandissement des villes
la densification des villes que soit ce
littoral sur les pentes n'a pas été lié
avec un agrandissement des réseaux
notamment d'eau pluviale des évacuations
d'eaux pluviales
on a construit beaucoup sans quelques
fois adapté en conséquence les réseaux
d'aujourd'hui vous direz c'est sous
dimensionné c'est sous dimensionné
encore la totalité des réseaux d'eaux
pluviales à la région sont actuellement
très sous dimensionné la difficulté pour
réparer cette erreur d'équipement c'est
que autant l'eau potable
héloïse et sont subventionnés l'eau
pluviale les équipements de pluvial ne
sont pas subventionnées et donc par
conséquent les collectivités ont
beaucoup de mal à investir pour
réadapter
évidemment ces équipements d'eau
pluviale vous savez c'est ce sont ces
grosses buses que l'on voit évidemment
sur les routes
à chaque fois que vous faites des
travaux d'eaux pluviales ça coûte très
cher et donc forcément les collectivités
n'ont pas la même dynamique souvent
réadapter le réseau d'eaux pluviales
car construire car et urbanisé sur des
terrains en pente et donc c'est vrai
qu'il y à une sorte d'inadaptation
d'inadéquation entre les réseaux d'eaux
pluviales et l'extension urbaine sur
notre territoire
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire dans l'avenir
parce qu'on continue à construire la
population des réunions continuer
d'augmenter on va approcher le million
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous diriez
vous attention à tel ou tel ou tel point
il faut être particulièrement vigilant
oui j'ai demandé notamment dans le cadre
des assises mais on va parler de thaler
que justement les réseaux d'eaux
pluviales puissent être financés
par des fonds européens notamment sur
les risques naturels
mais peut être globalement mieux
financés par l'état parce qu'il s'agit
là d'un problème qui va être récurrent
dans les années qui viennent
il faut que nous puissions mieux
canaliser mieux appréhender l'ensemble
des écoulements d'eaux pluviales dans
les bassins versants
je vous donne deux exemples à
saint-pierre puisque j'ai été
responsable de ce problème à
saint-pierre lorsque nous avons fait des
travaux de la rue des bons enfants et
des travaux de la zac du mal le mal le
tcsp
à chaque fois nous avons mis des
barreaux hydraulique dans la ville de
saint-pierre pour que tous les
écoulements amont de la ville puissent
être récupérés pour ses bars ou
hydraulique et puissent être renvoyés
dans l'estuaire de la rivière d'abord
afin d'éviter justement que tous les
ruissellements superficielle termine les
eaux de la ville puisse être déversée
dans le lagon et donc ça c'est une
barrière qui a été construite évidemment
dans le cas de l'aménagement urbain mais
on y gagnerait pour que dans toutes les
villes on puisse faire justement ces
barreaux hydraulique ces aménagements
hydrauliques pour éviter que l'eau
pluviale que ce soit l'eau des pentes
sur l'ouest où l'eau des urbaines arrive
évidemment sur ces milieux littoraux
parce que évidemment ça détruit
l'ensemble des récifs david orient tant
qu'on est dans l'aménagement de l'espace
et des questions d'urbanisme je voudrais
bien connaître votre avis sur la
politique de la ville du gouvernement
vous avez écrit lors de la visite de
jean-louis borloo la mairie de saint
pierre nous rêvions d'un grand soir de
la politique de la ville nous avons eu
en matière de communication un beau
coucher de soleil du président de la
république ya rien à rien à sauver dans
la politique actuelle annoncée par le
gouvernement mais à écouter c'est
l'étonnement tout à fait entre ce qui a
été dit par jean louis borloo missionné
par le président de la république pour
mettre en place un grand plan d'eau
missionné pour faire le rapport
vivement le rapport qu un peu déçu il
nous apparaît présenté comme ça jean
louis borloo nous a dit je suis
missionné pour mettre en place des
mesures qui vont être adoptés par le
gouvernement et je vais m'appliquer
évidemment à expliquer en quoi ces
mesures sont bonnes j'allais être ici
que vous a convaincu oui j'ai été séduit
par ces mesures parce que ces mesures
prenait en compte évidemment les aspects
d'investissement au sein globalis les
aspects aussi d'éducation des écoles
mais aussi l'ensemble des aspects
économiques notamment d'intégration et
j'avais l'impression qu'on revenait à ce
qu'on appelle la boîte à outils de
borloo allende rue dans son la première
version c'est à dire qu'ils étaient
lorsque réaménager la ville dans sa
globalité et d'avoir les moyens
évidemment pour le faire oui parce
qu'une question de moyens quand même et
puis on arrive évidemment dans un
discours du prenant république où on a
trois quarts du temps des aspects très
sécuritaire rien sur la réhabilitation
des quartiers très dégradée comme on en
a la réunion est évidemment un discours
qui est très très générales sur les
financements qui apparemment ne sont pas
plus importants nous serons encore moins
important qu'avant
et puis quelques mesurettes évidemment
sur des stages etc
j'ai été extrêmement déçus comme
d'ailleurs tous les politiques de la
réunion sur cette vision de la politique
de la ville parce que ne répondent en
aucun cas à l'amélioration des quartiers
tels que nous pouvions imaginer
évidemment à la suite du la visite du
rapport du borloo
quelles seraient les les points les plus
importants si on devait garder quelque
chose justement du plan borloo imaginons
qu'ils reviennent sur la table vous il
ya des choses qui dedans vous dites
voilà ça c'est la bonne solution pour
nos quartiers réunion vous savez souvent
il faut il faut aborder un point
particulier lorsqu'on est dans le pré de
la ville je pense que l'éducation est
quelque chose d'important
si on arrivait à faire prendre
conscience qu'un quartier qui réussit
est un quartier qui forment bien depuis
la maternelle
en passant par le primaire en passant
par le collège en passant par lycée et
puis même dans les formations
supérieures qui est vraiment un travail
en commun entre l'ensemble des
enseignements avec les parents d'élèves
et le fait que dans ce quartier on
puisse réussir ça sera pas forcément
très cher ça coûte pas forcément très
cher mais ça demande un investissement
dans
les bâtiments scolaires ça demain un
investissement en temps avec des
équipements en informatique sa demande
qu'on y met les moyens pour que les
élèves qui sont dans les quartiers se
disent dans ce quartier je peux réussir
et surtout éviter autre chose qui est
bien connu à la réunion ce qu'on appelle
le phénomène d'évitement certains
parents qui ont les moyens vont éviter
d'inscrire leurs enfants dans ce
quartier pour aller inscrire dans un
autre quartier
est ce cet évitement la bine fait que le
quartier est de plus en plus reculés et
marché vous diriez que à saint pierre
par exemple vous avez de plus en plus de
mal à conserver une mixité sociale
la mixité sociale c'est je vous dis
l'éducation on arrive à la construire
cette mixité sociale lorsqu'on réussit
et une équité de l'éducation les parents
qui ont les moyens aucun réussi se
disent mais si dans ce quartier j'ai une
bonne école je vais rester dans ce
quartier mais la mixité ça se construit
d'abord par l'éducation et ensuite une
fois qu'on allait ducation une fois
qu'on a les services de proximité une
fois qu'on a les services commerciaux à
proximité le quartier change de visage
et ce quartier qui change de visage
c'est la politique de la ville on a un
peu le sentiment que les décideurs
politiques on parle beaucoup de poids
quand il s'agit de politique de logement
vous allez me dire que peut-être à
saint-pierre ça s'est passé autrement
mais les logements globalement l'arrêt
nommant que les réhabilitations ne se
font pas toujours le vieillissement de
la population on a l'impression qu'il
n'a pas été tellement anticipée alors
qu'il arrivait qui va poser de vrais
soucis de logement pourquoi ce que les
pouvoirs publics les élus ne peuvent pas
assurer ce droit fondamental au logement
à tous les réunionnais il ya loire vous
savez qui s'analyse et et être discutée
la semaine prochaine qui sape la loi et
dans vous avez espoir pour sa dévolution
du logement à l'aménagement numérique
je vais intervenir dans la discussion
générale pendant cinq minutes
le groupe a demandé évidemment de le
faire et je suis assez critique encore
sur cette loi est lent parce que on
avait souhaité que dans cette loi il y
est évidemment des choses beaucoup plus
intéressantes évidemment pour la réunion
ce n'est pas le cas les autres maires ne
sont encore une fois
encore une fois l'angle mort la
politique du gouvernement il n'y a rien
sur les autres
j'avais notamment défendre le
rétablissement des apl accession
bien évidemment c'est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe parce que le fait
de devenir propriétaire pour une famille
qui va emprunter et qui dansaient
autorisation de prêt sont limite de
retirer cet aide d'état 1 va faire
perdre le rêve de ce parcours
résidentiel une fois que vous êtes dans
une location et que vous accédez
évidemment une propriété on appelle la
case à terre ce rêve de la case à terre
vous le perdez en supprimant la pm le
fait de supprimer la paix elle supprime
aussi les constructions et c'est à dire
l'ensemble des entreprises des petites
entreprises l'ensemble des services qui
vont pouvoir construire l'ensemble des
organisations telles que le bourbon bois
ou d'autres organisations qui construit
ces logements sociaux le logement social
accession à la propriété sous forme de
logement social c'est un aboutissement
d'un parcours est vous avez été entendu
qu'en même temps le gouvernement déjà là
dessus dont il ya plus ou moins des
promesses avoir un effet mais pas du
tout non plus tôt aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire que non aujourd'hui les
dossiers en cours on nous a dit qu'ils
allaient traiter en tout cas aujourd'hui
ne sont pas encore traitées et la
situation pour la fin de l'année elle
est toujours en discussion réflexion et
de nouvelles sont franchement pas bonne
vous avez parlé des assises on va y
revenir parce que derrière ces assises
alors est ce que vous y croyez vous à
ces assises qui que dont on devrait
avoir les résultats quoique d'ici un
mois
il va ya voir où nous à dire
effectivement la fin du mois de juin
mais c'est repoussé de 15 jours en
quinze jours vous avez dit femmes et là
on me dit vous avez dit 15 juin là on ne
dit fin juin je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas qu'est ce qui va être qu'est ce que
c'est que ces assises
on nous parle d'un livre bleu avec une
compilation évidemment de l'ensemble des
projets nous dit qu'il y aura plus de
1000 projets liste est un peu à la
prévert mais la difficulté de ça c'est
que pendant un an on a on s'est réuni on
s'est assis on a discuté enfin pas trop
les élus mais essentiellement les
associations les entreprises
plus de 1000 projets sont sortis
sûrement des projets intéressants à
l'intérieur qui va qui va les financer
quelles sont les priorités qu'est ce qui
constitue la colonne vertébrale du
gouvernement pour les outre-mer comment
on va les choisir à ces questions on n'a
pas de réponse est donc ce que je crains
c'est que ce soit une politique de
l'affichage voilà on a affiché des
projets et encore une fois on va dire
grosso modo débrouillez vous avec les
collectivités et puis on va vous aider
avec l'état quand les projets sont
intéressants
ça ne peut pas constituer un projet
politique pour l'outre-mer la politique
c'est une histoire de sous de combien
d'impôts l'état où les collectivités
écoles de ce qu'ils en font là pour
faire simple la doctrine de la droite
libérale qui semble être celle des
moniales macro et l'heure philips et de
limiter autant que possible la dépense
publique de pas trop imposer
d'entreprises privées pour qu'elles se
développent qu'elle crée de l'emploi
est-ce que c' est ce que c'est cette
politique dont la réunion a besoin
est ce qu'elle est serait bénéfique à
notre territoire
d'abord la politique ces gens là c'est
rendre les gens heureux
les autres ce sont les moyens
ce sont des outils rendre les gens
heureux c'est que les gens puissent
accéder à des services sociaux
lorsqu'ils en ont besoin
c'est d'accéder à un service de santé
c'est d'accéder à un service d'éducation
c'est de faire en sorte que chacun
puisse avoir les mêmes chances dans la
vie et donc il faut des services publics
qu'ils soient gratuits qui soit payée
par l'impôt et donc l'objectif c'est
celui-là mais il faut aussi que les gens
puissent travailler et donc aider des
entreprises
alors ça ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
oui ça coûte de l'argent bien évidemment
ça coûte de l'argent mais il faut qu'on
ait un système qui est un système qui a
toujours hésité à la française celui
d'un impôt assez élevé pour qu'on ait
des services sociaux qui fonctionne et
donc moi je ne suis pas du tout pour une
baisse d'impôts drastiques
parce que je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr
à l'exemple de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis en angleterre que lorsque les
entreprises fonctionnent bien et gagne
beaucoup d'argent
elle reverse voudrions la totalité de
cet argent aux salariés chris evans
persuadé je ne crois pas aux ficelles
hélas le récent rapport d'oxfam montre
que lorsque les entreprises gagnent de
l'argent
elle ne leur verse pas aux ans aux
salariés mais à leur verse aux
actionnaires et donc l'état à ce rôle à
jouer qui est un rôle de défense du
service public de défense de la santé de
l'éducation du bien-être de chacun du
logement est un service qui est un
service d'action politique d'action
sociale c'est le rôle de l'état
le rôle de l'état n'est pas seulement de
favoriser les entreprises ont fait
naître une gagnent de l'argent et que
cet argent ruisselle par rapport aux
actionnaires aux salariés
on croirait entendre un élu de gauche je
suis pas un élu de gauche mais je vous
ai dit lors de notre dernière interview
je suis un élu de droite mais un élu de
droite de la droite sociale gaulliste
qui estime qu'un état doit d'abord
préserver les acquis sociaux et doit
tout faire pour que ces acquis sociaux
fonctionnent bien
maintenant il faut évidemment trouver un
moyen jeu d'accord pour dire que c'est
pas tout à fait le discours de votre
parti politique et de vos partenaires
politiques je sais mais seul bien de
discours je suis pas attaché points et
bien lié un discours ou un parti
politique je l'expliqué dans un instant
et je crois que emmanuel macron certes
privilégier les entreprises parce qu'il
souhaite évidemment que ces entreprises
soient plus dynamiques gagnent plus
d'argent investissent et innove et c'est
vrai qu'il ya aussi une volonté et que
c'est son choix mais il faut faire
attention que pour cela on ne casse pas
tout le service public en france
vous êtes pour la multiplication de
zones franches ou de secteurs francs
pour développer l'économie à la réunion
d entre eux pleurent plutôt des secteurs
d'activité qui serait exonérée de
charges plutôt que des domaines
géographiques est ce que c'est une piste
intéressante pour créer de l'emploi
alors c'est une piste qui a été analysée
dans le cas de la revue des aides
économiques à la région en ce moment
même pour lequel on aurait aimé aussi
être pour ce serait insulter vrai les
rêves mère vous a été vexé de pas être
plus partie prenante dans cette
réflexion sais pas c'est pas que je suis
vexé j'ai suffisamment de travail comme
ça c'est pas du tout ça c'est que un
moment donné lorsqu'ils vont présenter
leurs résultats je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient les réponses attendues la réforme
ou la revue des aides économiques
c'est d'abord l'assurance quand la
réunion les entreprises qui veulent se
lancer et les mêmes conditions notamment
financières que les entreprises
européennes va les conditions
en clair l'aide de l'abbé pays par
exemple et des conditions minimales
lorsqu'on veut innover c'est cette
ingénierie financière qui manque la bcrg
la banque publique d'investissement qui
est donc les entreprises tout à fait les
entreprises qui veulent se lancer la
réunion parfois beaucoup de mal à
trouver les financements nécessaires
pour le faire et donc il faut à la
réunion que le gouvernement s'engage la
deuxième chose c'est que si on veut
mettre une loi il faut faire une loi
programme
il faut donner de la visibilité sur une
dizaine d'années et pas seulement nous
dire je vais retransformer le projet de
loi de finances pour m évidemment sans
des changements économiques à la reine
passe quand on perdrait cette vision en
dix ans et donc moi j'ai beaucoup
insisté pour que ce soit une loi
programme
la troisième chose vous avez été entendu
pour l'instant je n'en sais rien
puisqu'on n'a encore pas de nouvelles de
la revue des aides économiques
la troisième chose c'est que 80% des
aides vont à 20% des entreprises et donc
là il ya quelque chose qui me semble pas
tout à fait normal c'est une question de
taille d'entreprise c'est une question
de seine question de l'été réseau c'est
une question de mécanique des aides
la réforme des aides qui s'est passé par
exemple en vals aunis en belgique a
permis sous forme de l'aide sous forme
de chèques attribuent à des entreprises
en fonction de leur besoin de mieux
cibler d'une part les besoins des
entreprises de mieux cibler les tailles
d'entreprises et donc l'accompagnement
des entreprises
j'aurais qu'on réfléchisse un prune
procédure dead qui accompagne mieux les
petites entreprises qui leur donnent des
aides qu'ils soient spécifiques à leurs
besoins dans le cadre de la formation
dans le cadre de l'investissement et
qu'on réfléchisse en fait à ce que
l'aide n'arrive pas globalement parce
que certes il ya 2,5 milliards d'êtres
qu'arrive à lannion mais que leur soient
mieux ciblés pour chacune des
entreprises et donc je réponds à votre
question sur les aides zone et les aides
zone et ça ça fonctionne pas on a trois
aides zone et la za dr la zone de
revitalisation rurale qui est la partie
haute de la réunion dans laquelle
justement vous n'avez pas assez
d'entreprises
vous avez une deuxième aide qui est la
zélée fut la zone franche urbaine et
donc vous concentrer l'aide que sur une
toute petite partie du territoire et
donc que vous avez des boîtes aux
lettres qui vont s'installer vous n'avez
pas vraiment d'entreprise
vous avez des à défaire les zones
franches d'activités ou là vous avez
évidemment une aide qui est plus
intéressante mais qui va concerner que
évidemment un certain nombre d'activités
que dans une petite partie du territoire
je crois qu'il faut revoir cette zone et
installé un port franc parce que notre
port doit être un port où il n'y a pas
de taxe pour faire venir un certain
nombre de croisiéristes faire venir un
certain nombre de l'entreprise avec une
zone franche autour évidemment du port
on peut imaginer que cette zone franche
soit dans des pôles d'intérêts régionaux
tels que pierre fontelle que la zone
roland-garros telles que le port de la
pointe des galets et il faut donner une
visibilité une concentration des aides
te ment sur ces zones franches là où il
ya des portes d'entrée notamment de guy
de la région on pourrait on imaginer une
dans l'est à saint-andré aussi imaginé
jean paul virapoullé à ce projet la
scapa un peu de contradiction à vouloir
exonérer de charges dans certaines
entreprises et en même temps dire bah il
faut continuer à avoir de l'impôt il
faut continuer à développer les services
publics le 3 nuls il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas à rougir de sa toutes les îles ont
ce désavantage d'être des îles soeurs de
petit territoire est très éloignée d'un
espace continental pour attirer mais
compensé pour attirer des entreprises
lorsque vous êtes une île comme la note
il faut leur donner les avantages
spécifiques et l' avantage de payer
moins de taxes comme l'avantagé payer
moins d'impôts lorsqu'on est vite y sont
les avantages qui ont fait leurs preuves
dans l'ensemble des autres îles du monde
qui fonctionne de la même manière
donc il faut pas voir cela comme des
avantages indus il faut voir comme une
conséquence géographique de notre
localisation de notre éloignement de
notre insularité
c'est notre seule manière de nous en
tirer par rapport à l'espace continental
qui a évidemment beaucoup plus
d'avantagés économiques que nous on va
faire une petite pause musicale vous
avez comme interpète intermède pardon et
l'audio célimène patrick sida et david
waro à la guitare en écoutant un morceau
ça s'appelle laisse pas sega freddy
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
deux virtuoses à la guitare ses duos
célimène patrick si david avoir choisi
partager leur vie pour ce show david
orient en un mot je connais très bien
les deux guitaristes on faisait nos
études ensemble à paris j'ai vu les
premières notes de la et de l'autre et
je trouve que ce sont deux interprètes
extraordinaire de la musique
réunionnaise
ils ont fait un duo s'est rendu au plan
sciences des états de 2007-2009 je crois
il continue à jouer ensemble ce sont
deux professeurs géniaux et j'adore les
écouter david lorion faut-il que la
réunion île vers plus d'autonomie dans
sa fiscalité dans sa façon de gérer les
emplois faut-il notamment toucher à la
constitution et supprimer le fameux
amendement virapoullé qui est que la
réunion de la possibilité de certaines
adaptations locales des lois nationales
on va on va demain à 7 meur ici on se
dans ce studio on va faire des bras sur
sur cette évolution constitutionnelle et
des institutions réunionnaise mais que
vous serez pas là demain donc je vous
demande aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes
déjà prononcé sur ce sujet vous votre
position c'est quoi d'abord il faut dire
la chose tout à fait clairement les
peuples sont libres et les réunionnais
sont libres de leur choix
ils élisent des élus qui sont libres la
liberté ça fait partie des droits de
l'homme la liberté du choix du disposer
d'eux-mêmes disposer de la politique
qu'ils veulent et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on dise de manière claire dans la
révision constitutionnelle qui est en
train de s'écrire en ce moment qu'on
doit les réunionnais nous avoir la même
liberté que n'importe quel autre dogme
la liberté de quoi on est une région ou
un département français
c'est écrit et personne ne revient sur
cette situation
nous sommes une région un département
français qui devront appliquer les mêmes
lois que celles qui se trouvent en
métropole mais avec une capacité
nouvelle que nous donne la l'écriture de
cette constitution
la capacité d'adapter les lois et les
règlements que ce soit dans les
compétences de nos propres collectivités
où que ce soit hors compétence de notre
collectivité c'est ça la liberté et donc
il faut qu'on soit les deux en même
temps il faut qu'on soit un département
et une région française et qu'on n'ait
pas peur de le dire mais qui en même
temps à la liberté d'adapter la
législation et les règlements quand
c'est nécessaire évidemment de le faire
en gros ce que vous proposez c'est une
réécriture dont cet article 73 avec
sabine et à 5,10 amendement virapoullé
qui une réécriture qui dirait qu'on est
bien un département une région si on n'y
touche pas pas de collectivités uniques
mais qu' on pourrait comme les autres
départements adapter les lois jean paul
virapoullé dit il faut pas faire ça il
faut pas aller vers ça et quand jean
hugues ratenon par exemple demande à
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne supprime pas cet amendement le
gouvernement lui répond si tous les
parlementaires réunionnais vous êtes
d'accord on y va mais quand vous n'êtes
pas d'accord dont on bouge pas alors
d'abord c'est pas un amendement c'est
allé là linéaire en fait qu'elle est née
après la dig et à 5
d'abord l'année à saintes n'existe plus
aujourd'hui puisque la dont la prochaine
recrue tu resteras prochaine lecture
l'article 73 complètement été réécrit et
dans cet article 69 route et encore ce
n'est pas voté mais le dossier a été
transcrit re au conseil d'état enfin
pour savoir si c'est au conseil
constitutionnel pour savoir si c'est
dans la constitution et ça a été rendu
donc gouvernement donc dès le mois de
juillet je pense que ça va être soumis
au parlement mais il faut donc 5e 308 et
les sénateurs réunis en tout cas sur
l'article 73 dans la réécriture qui en
est fait aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut
trouver une solution à mi-chemin entre
ce que dit jean paul et l'esprit que la
réunion reste française est ce que dit
jean hugues ratenon qui est de dire
allons vers une autonomie
je pense qu'il faut être droit dans ses
bottes
quelque part réaffirmé ses opinions moi
la mienne est clair la région et le
département de la réunion sont français
et nous avons le droit comme tous les
autres départements d'outre-mer
d'adapter les lois et les règlements
compte évidemment ça c'est nécessaire
pour nous parce que nous sommes un
peuple libre et nous pouvons adapter les
lois et les règlements lorsque ça nous
convient
paraissait tout à fait naturel le faire
puisque à la réunion mon dieu on n'a pas
tout à fait le même climat nous n'avons
pas tout à fait le même éloignement ne
se fera pas tout à fait sur la même île
que un territoire métropolitain
on a vu tout à l'heure le problème des
eaux pluviales on ne peut pas traiter à
la réunion de la même manière les eaux
pluviales que un autre département
métropolitain qui a cinquante fois moins
de pluviométrie qu'il existe à l'arrière
voilà vous êtes député est ce que vous
êtes content ou est ce que c'est pour ça
que vous avez voulu faire de la
politique ce que ça vous satisfait cette
première année côté c'est un peu une
date anniversaire
c'est un métier très compliqué sur le
plan familial et je salue vraiment mes
enfants et ma femme parce que ils ont
ils ont souffert de l'absence évidemment
de leur père leur mari c'est quelque
chose qui est compliqué qui demande
beaucoup de travail parce que les jours
on est présent évidemment à l'assemblée
nationale on concentre tous les rendez
vous et en concentre tout le travail qui
est à faire lorsqu'on revient ici on à
rendre compte évidemment et à participer
à des réunions des manifestations et
travaille avec les collaborateurs
toutes les semaines tous les quinze
jours on a cette situation d'être dans
un lieu puis dans un autre pour
travailler différemment et je salue
l'ensemble de mes collègues députés
c'est un travail qui est difficile qui
est exaltant puisqu'on touche évidemment
comme vous l'avez vu à la constitution
soit dix roues loi fondatrice évidemment
notre vie en commun on touche à l'avenir
la réunion de par les lois qui sont
prises et en même temps on a beaucoup de
regrets parce qu'on n'est pas
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale
lorsque je cite ma collègue rica eric a
fait un amendement hier soir et elle dit
dans l'agriculture la loi sur
l'agriculture il faut exclure les
produits dégagement la réunion parce
qu'on s'a en train de tuer l'ensemble de
notre production
elle n'est pas écouté lorsque elle dit
encore il faut que on supprime la
publicité pour les bonbons sucrés pour
les enfants elle n'est pas écouté et on
a de terribles recrues lorsqu'on a dit
tous les uns et les autres ne supprimez
pas les appels et les contrats aidés
parce qu'à la réunion on en a besoin
parce qu'on n'est pas dans une situation
où lorsqu'on recherche un travail on
peut changer de région est allé dans le
département d'à côté pour en trouver un
on n'est pas écoutés et donc en même
temps c'est exaltant parce qu'on fait
des choses vraiment importantes et puis
en même temps on a des regrets qui sont
terribles est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment sur pour revenir sur justement
la façon dont les choses se passent à
l'assemblée aujourd'hui ce que vous avez
senti vexé après tout c'est ça la
démocratie un parti qui est majoritaire
est très majoritaire et qui prend les
décisions qui veut ou es ce que vous
avez l'impression que ben il ya un peu
plus que ça c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
d' espace pour une expression d'une
démocratie la démocratie mais en place
évidemment une majorité et ça a toujours
fonctionné
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
est dans une période de transition de la
vie politique française
la population française les électeurs
ont un roger des élus aujourd'hui très
clairement les élus sont plus vus comme
des personnes qui profitent d'une
situation je peux vous dire que beaucoup
d'élus sont des élus qui travaillent d
elui qui s'investissent et forcément on
a quelque part souffrante situation
d'être un peu incompris moi ce que je
regrette avant tout c'est que l'élection
de l'assemblée nationale actuelle est
une majorité d'élus qui sont des
nouveaux élus pour certains d'entre eux
ils n'ont jamais été ne serait-ce que
dans un conseil municipal et donc qu'on
a l'impression que les décisions qu'ils
prennent sont des décisions un peu
superficielle cosmétiques
par exemple je vois les décisions qui
concernent les vidéos dans les abattoirs
certes pourquoi pas mais ça me paraît
quand même plus intéressant d'interdire
les bonbons sucrés aux enfants parce
qu'il ya des dégâts irrémédiables pour
leur santé que de mettre des vidéos dans
les abattoirs et donc on a une sorte de
grande confusion des gens en fonction
des désinvestissements des uns des
autres en fonction des influences des
associations et on n'a pas le sens des
réalités souvent dans la majorité qui
est en place vous parliez de
chamboulement du paysage politique et de
la façon dont les citoyens probablement
géré leurs relations avec les parties
avec les élus
et vous vous êtes membre du parti des
républicains
est ce que vous êtes toujours en phase
avec laurent wauquiez de président de
votre parti pour qui vous avez voté me
semble-t-il pour la présidence du parti
est-ce que vous vous sentez en phase
avec le discours qu'il porte est-ce que
notamment l'obsession de certains cadres
du parti et notamment pour les questions
d'identité de religion d'immigration
l'islam est ce que ça vous bon
honnêtement j'ai ça vous correspond pas
trop je suis pour l'instant député
république a et je suis sûr que oui pour
l'instant et je suis l'un des députés
qui a voté le plus de décision du
gouvernement m'a cros a d'ailleurs été
relevés dans l'article du monde sur le
choix des députés
donc je suis évidemment pas toujours
mais je suis assez souvent favorable
avec les décisions du gouvernement
donc vous voyez que je suis tout à fait
disposé à travailler
que ce soit avec la ministre de
l'outre-mer où que ce soit avec le
gouvernement macron je crois qu'à un
moment donné il y à une majorité qui est
légitime il propose des actions
je suis d'acord travailler avec avec
edouard philippe je suis d'acord
travailler avec la ménitré outre mer ça
ne veut pas dire que j'accepte tout la
politique gouvernementale je vous ai dit
que pour l'instant cette politique
gouvernementale faisait d'énormes
sacrifices sur les services publics et
les personnes et qui étaient les plus
défavorisés et ça me convient pas mais
ça me convient pas non plus aujourd'hui
la ligne directrice de notre parti je ne
suis pas un aficionados de la sécurité
simplement peut-être parce que je ne vis
pas spécialement à paris ou à lyon ou à
marseille
je comprends bien mes collègues députés
républicains qui en fait un cheval de
bataille parce qu'à un moment donné
lorsqu'on n'est pas en sécurité et ben
on ne peut pas vivre tout court
je ne suis pas un aficionados de la
politique anti immigration
parce que ça n'a pas de sens lorsqu'on
vit à la réunion mais je comprends bien
que dans certaines situations lorsqu'on
habite à porte champerret ou lorsqu'on
est dans le 19ème à paris lorsqu'on voit
des camps de migrants qui ne savent pas
où aller et sur lesquelles personne ne
peut rien faire ni le maire de paris ni
le gouvernement commence à poser
problème de drogue d'insécurité
je comprends bien que les agriculteurs
ou les industriels n'ai pas envie d'une
europe qui gouverne tout est donc la
ligne vos kékidi fait attention cette
europe nous convient pas il faut changer
d'europe
je comprends les demandes de des lignes
républicaine de mon parti mais ce n'est
pas mêlé ce ne sont pas mes priorités
mon rôle en tant que député républicain
c'est tous les jours de leur dire en
outre mer il faut une politique
française qui soit une politique de
rayonnement de la france dans le monde
dans les bassins océaniques nous avons
plus d'atomes crochus avec madagascar
avec l'afrique du sud avec l'inde ou
avec l'australie qu'avec l'autriche ou
avec la suisse où avec l'espagne est
donc quelque part notre situation c'est
la france dans le monde
notre situation c'est la place de la
france dans le monde et il faut que les
gouvernements nous fassent confiance là
dessus il faut qu'à un moment donné on
est la compétence qui soit dans les
collectivités ou hors collectivités pour
qu'on puisse par délégation du
gouvernement français allait négocier
ensemble de traiter économiques ou
politiques avec les pays de la zone
c'est ça notre rôle excusez moi de
revenir à une version peut-être un peu
plus politiciennes des choses mais je
vous entends dire pour l'instant je suis
les républicains on sait que ici à la
réunion
voilà didier robert franchi le cap il a
quitté les républicains pour se
rapprocher d'une ligne plus pour dire
gouvernementale michel fontaine inverse
lui est resté très proche des
républicains et des fonds plutôt la
ligne de laurent wauquiez ou est ce que
vous êtes et ce que vous allez je suis
ainsi nos racines je suis républicain je
suis fidèle de michel fontaine
je suis tout à fait loyal avec la
politique régionale et je trouve qu'il
ya des choses importantes qui sont
faites mais j'ai ma propre ligne
politique
je ne cesse de dire à laurent wauquiez
que je vois tous les mercredis parce
qu'ils y admirer en groupe à christian
jacob qui ne présentent groupe
vous ne faites pas assez pour
l'outre-mer et vous devriez vous engagez
plus clairement dans une politique vous
républicain dans une politique de la
france d'outre-mer et que si à un moment
donné vous le faites pas les outre mer
ne vont pas se reconnaître en vous et
vont chercher d'autres partis donc c'est
une caisse
survie pour nous députés autres maires
soit vous le faites c'est au tour nous
entende et entendu j'essaie j'essaie
d'être entendu et je le dis comme vous à
ce micro il faut qu'on nous foute façon
passer ce message parce que chez les
autres ne sommes pas plus entendu chez
makro ne sommes pas plus entendu j'ai
écrit tout un article la semaine
dernière d'un journal en dix ans la
politique gouvernementale fait d outre
mer un angle mort nous sommes pas plus
entendu non plus au front national nous
sommes pas plus entendu non plus celle à
gauche et donc par conséquent il faut
qu'à un moment donné les outre-mer se
fassent entendre les outre mer c'est une
partie de la france et une partie
importante de la france
quand je vois par exemple je vous dis en
deux mots la chine se battent mètre
carré par mètre carré pour concerner
l'ensemble des îles notamment en pays en
mer de chine
je ne comprend pas que la france fasse
est au centre réticence à soutenir ses
autres maires pour que la france soit
présente dans le monde entier
en un mot pas rouillé uno en 2020 où
vous serez candidat à la mairie de saint
pierre où on verra quelque part avec
l'étiquette en 2020 je souhaite que
michel fontaine soit candidat à la
mairie de saint-pierre et je serai son
premier soutien merci david lorion
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir après des
infos leurs deux minutes c'est l'audi
qui vous accompagne d'un matin jérôme
galabert sera l'invité de philippe
dernier sept heures pour parler du
sakifo
et puis demain soir donc débat sur
l'avenir la réforme de la constitution